Why was a dream
as we heard in our son
a very well-known story probably most of
us know this story
the story of Ku
is The man from
he was one of the followers of
was actually related to Musa.
He was his cousin, direct cousin.
Some say on his father's side, others
say on his mother's. However,
the scholars of Tia
are unanimous
on
the fact that
was
related to Lusa as his direct cousin.
is considered to be an analogy, a
cautionary tale
that a person not believe his own hype.
Now many of us know the
basic premise of this story.
What is the basic premise? The basic
premise is anything that you have, you
are not to be a braggard. You are not to
ascribe it to yourself. Rather, you are
to ascribe that blessing to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
However, we need to examine this story a
little bit deeper.
Allah was blessed with a huge amount of
money. We don't know how much. We don't
know what kind of wealth. We don't know
where he got this wealth from.
story is different. He's mentioned
in the Tawa
and he's mentioned again as a cautionary
tale,
but the ins and outs of exactly how he
acquired his wealth. Allah doesn't go
into that and it's irrelevant honestly.
What's important is that Paul had so
much wealth
that
the keys
of the safes for his wealth could not be
lifted or transported.
That's how much he had.
He had this all locked up in his home.
and his people
they reminded him. Now something
interesting we should know about before
we continue is that wasn't just a
reluctant follower of Musa
was considered the most recited of the
almost all the followers of Mus time all
of them.
all of them.
He was the most memorized, most
well-versed and the most beautiful
recitation of the Torah and all of the
followers of Musa.
He was given all this wealth
and of course his people being that they
were believers.
The common
the common
saying amongst them or the common
theme of their advice to him was
use that wealth that Allah has given you
to obtain Allah's pleasure
and sure enjoy some of it yourself but
as Allah has been good to you beans what
would every Muslim reply
to worship Allah Right? That's that's
the answer. If you were to say where did
you get your health and your wealth from
to anyone any would they say from Allah.
There's a difference between saying the
right things and believing them.
Because most people say I have been
created for the worship of Allah with
their lifestyle. Does their lifestyle
say that about them?
Do most people's words articulate
when we read between the lines
articulate that they really believe
that they have received all good from
Allah?
The answer is no.
Because there's a difference between
what we say and what we believe and what
will be judged. Our words were our
actions. Our actions
will not
your image
raentions,
your hearts and your actions. This is
what we are judged by. When we are
placed in our brain, when we are asked
what will be, we don't answer with that
part of our mind that says that reads
the room and says whatever should be
said, whatever is appropriate, whatever
is popular.
Rather, we answer that with what? With
our actions, with how we live, that's
what will answer those questions. No
amount of intelligence
will help a person during that test.
And so
he said a very interesting thing. Now
remember what do we know about? First of
all, he comes from Moses family. His
father and M's father were brothers.
Okay, number one. Number two, he was
considered the most
recited, most knowledgeable of the Tal
in his time.
And number three, he was given an
incredible amount of wealth.
We have to think about this for a
second.
The Quran is truly a miracle. When Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala quotes
people to us in the Quran,
does he tell us from them exactly what
they said with their words? Exactly.
Exactly. Exactly.
Well, no, of course not. We know that
for a fact because most of the words
that are are told to us and most of the
quotes weren't even in Arabic to begin
with. They were in other languages.
The words of the words of the words of
the people of the world and the words of
the government, they weren't in. If
Allah was quoting,
that would mean that Pharaoh was as
eloquent as the Quran in his speech. Of
course not.
But does Allah tell us in so many words
what they said? Or does he tell us what
they really said?
This is the point here. He tells us what
they really said.
And that's why some of their arguments
sound absurd because Allah is not
quoting to us the roundabout way that
they go arguing on behalf of falsehood.
He tells us the gist of their arguments
and the gist of their argument is
absurd.
For instance, the people of
they try to drive out of their land,
right?
Why did they say that in Nazareth?
They said drive you and his family out
from amongst you. They seek to be pure.
Did they say they seek to be pure
through those words? No.
They seek to they said they are they are
xenophobic. They don't care about love.
They have hatred. They're hateful
people. That's how they said it. But
really, what were they saying in the Old
Testament?
When the people were persecuting the
prophets and messengers, they weren't
persecuting them saying
they need to be killed because they say
that.
No, they have a many different ways of
articulating that. They are trying to
ruin your forefather's image. They just
want to say that they're prophets.
They're not really prophets. They're
liars. They want to just worship their
own god. They want to introduce a new
god propaganda.
But when Allah quotes them to us, he's
quoting what they really said, not the
arguments and the dust that people like
to bring up in order to throw people off
of their sense.
The same thing here with
our equivalent of a Muslim today. And
just every single Muslim,
no matter how arrogant they may be, no
matter how much they feel that they are
whatever Allah gives them, they wouldn't
say in a listening environment I am a
success. Allah didn't give me anything.
They wouldn't say that because that's
shameful in that environment. Instead,
they'll say that in a way,
right?
let me ask you a question. If I
said to you right now,
I am so knowledgeable. I am very
knowledgeable. I memorize this and that.
You know what? I am so knowledgeable. I
have this and that and I go on for 20 30
minutes about just how knowledgeable I
am and just how much you should view me
as such. But then at the end of that
half hour rant about all of my merits I
say
that's all for me.
Is that what I really said? Is that what
I really believe or is that just cheap
service
and I want a rant for half an hour
talking about how smart I am, how
skilled I am. People didn't know they
didn't trust me, but I knew I had a good
feeling. Ever since I was a kid, my dad
said I was so smart. My parents knew.
Everybody would marvel at my
intelligence. Everyone would marvel at
this and that. And I got so much money
and I did this and I did that and I did
this and that and that and I and I and I
and me and me and me.
Allah.
When does that when did I really say and
this is what really said
when said
he said I have been given this because
I'm special.
Did he really say that in those words?
Probably not. But that's what he really
meant. And if you read between the lines
and look to what his real conviction
was, that's what he believed. And that's
why Allah
says judges him a career at the end of
the story.
He said, "I have been given this because
of the knowledge I possess.
And it can also be understood as Allah
has given me this because he knows that
I am rightful. I am owed this. What's
interesting about the words is that the
exact words in Arabic could be
understood to be either of these two
things.
It can be in the mountain.
[Silence]
So the verse can be understood that I
have been given this because of the
knowledge I possess meaning I'm really
smart or he has been given this because
Allah knows him to be worthy of it
that he is rightful to it. Which one is
it? It's both. Allah intended that
ambiguity because this is what he said
on occasion if he ascribes it to Allah.
Yeah, Allah gave it to me, but he knows
I'm special. That's why he gave it to
me. I deserve it. Or he doesn't mention
Allah at all and refers it to his own
abilities.
That is the attitude.
And so
even though he recited the Torah
beautifully, he worked hard to memorize
the Torah, right? Why would he do that?
because he was obsessed with vanity
and the pleasure
of wealth and the pleasure of knowledge.
They run in the same vein in the human
being. The prophets
body
two types of people will never be
satisfied. The seeker of knowledge and
the seeker of wealth. they'll never be
satisfied.
And that's why the greatest insult to
any human being is to call that is to
insult their what? Their intelligence.
Because that's the hallmark of humanity.
Would you rather be referred to or
thought of as poor or thought of as
stupid,
right? Or thought of as as foolish.
Every one of us would choose what poor
anything but don't even if a person
knows he's foolish they still wouldn't
want to be referred to as such because
that is the greatest insult to any human
being. So the vanity of knowledge and
the vanity of wealth, they run in the
exact same vein. And we can even argue
that the people of knowledge, not the
people of the knowledge of the Quran and
the people of worldly knowledge or those
who seek knowledge of the Quran and
Sunnah for worldly gain, they are
arguably more prone to arrogance than
people of wealth.
knowledge is of anything.
And so
he said, I have been given this because
of a knowledge I possess. I have been
given this because Allah knows that I
deserve it.
And that is the critical mistake here.
And that is thinking that having a good
or being given what you desire in the
dunya is somehow a sign that Allah is
pleased with you. critical mistake.
Every disbeliever in history made that
same mistake.
And so
all we know, even though he recited the
Torah out of one of his faces,
from the other we know that all of this
was for the sake of vanity because he
came out in a huge procession showing
off all of his wealth.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us
will be dead.
Allah says that we cause the earth to
swallow him and his wealth. Now why does
Allah tell us that the wealth was
swallowed as wealth? Couldn't the people
have used that wealth?
Wouldn't that have been beneficial? like
we caused the earth to swallow but then
the wealth we needed right I mean this
took place while they were lost in the
desert fat
so why didn't Allah keep the wealth for
people to use
because this will emphasize the
importance of
we don't need you and we don't need your
wealth people of wealth that do not
ascribe their wealth to a love truly
think that the world cannot go on
without them.
All this wealth, all these workers, all
these people, they get their livelihood
from me. If my business goes belly up,
the world will fall apart. No, take your
wealth with you.
Allah will
do.
And that's why we see often that people
that are braggards about their wealth,
Allah destroys them and their wealth
with them. Because the knowledge that
Allah does not need a person's wealth is
arguably more important than the
knowledge the institutional knowledge
the law the legend that Allah didn't
need this person's wealth is arguably
more important for people to see than
the person himself the prophet
tells us in
we will end with this inshallah
Your
prophet sallall.aii
said, "A man left his home walking with
pride and arrogance,
viewing himself as, you know, with
arrogance,
dragging his clothing behind him,
meaning his clothes were very long, very
long, out of arrogance and vanity." And
this is
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala caused the
earth to swallow him. And he is
continuing to be swallowed until the day
of judgment.
So all right now, wherever he is, he is
currently being swallowed by the earth.
That is his punishment in the grave.
That he will continue to be swallowed
and devoured by the earth,
never ending until the day of judgment.
Why? Because the person who is arrogant
and this truly reaches the depths of his
heart, this person needs to be taught
and reminded in a constant way that they
are low, that they are nothing. The
prophet tells us the people of arrogance
on the day of judgment will be brought
forth be before Allah amongst the people
the size of tiny ants and people will be
trampling all over them. Why is that?
Because when they were alive they
thought people were little ants. They
were nothing. So Allah will bring them
forth in their true form on the day of
judgment. And that is that they are
tiny. They are nothing. They are
minuscule. They are bugs underneath
people's feet.
[Silence]
The dynamite is never going to work.
I turned it up. You never
[Arabic recitation]
What is this for you to so that nobody